Star Wars fans are thrilled that Jacen Syndulla
might walk the path of the Jedi — but the latest
Ahsoka episode suggests that things could
be about to get very dark, very quickly.
Ahsoka Tano is in a pickle. After being thoroughly
defeated by Baylan Skoll in the previous episode,
she spends the majority of Ahsoka's fifth part
trapped in the Force limbo known as the World
Between Worlds. Her experience there involves
multiple flashbacks to the war-torn days of
her youth, as well as a ghostly vision
of her old master, Anakin Skywalker,
who uses some characteristically aggressive
methods to complete his former Padawan's training.
Back in the physical world, Ahsoka's allies
struggle to track her down — and, once again,
strange Force antics end up saving
the day. Hera Syndulla's son, Jacen,
uses an impressive and clearly Force-enhanced
listening skill to get an idea of Ahsoka's
whereabouts, as he hears snippets of her
experience in the World Between Worlds.
"Don't you hear it?"
Known as Theran Force-listening, this ability
allows Force-users to hear things from great
distances. This power also has other handy
applications, such as allowing the user to
understand other languages. While not exactly
common in the live-action Star Wars universe,
many prominent Jedi characters have mastered
the trick in various "Legends" works.
The show's choice to give Jacen Theran
Force-listening abilities is particularly
interesting, as the skill is closely associated
with a similarly-named character from an extremely
dead corner of the Star Wars lore: Jacen
Solo, the son of Han Solo and Leia Organa.
In many ways, Jacen Solo is a scarier
Star Wars villain than Darth Vader. A
prominent character in non-canon Star Wars
novels, he starts out as a perfectly capable
Force-sensitive kid who eventually becomes a
powerful and respected hero. Unfortunately,
the plot of the books puts him through the kind of
wringer that would make his live-action
successor, Kylo Ren, run for the hills.
Jacen's path ultimately takes an
unfortunate turn, and unlike Kylo,
he goes all in on the Dark Side. As the Sith Lord
Darth Caedus, Jacen becomes something of a tragic
villain... but also a true terror who, among other
things, kills Luke Skywalker's wife, Mara Jade.
Any "Legends" fan will tell you that Darth
Caedus is one of the most overpowered
antagonists in the entire franchise, with a
laundry list of Force superpowers that put
him almost on par with Luke himself.
He's also notorious for picking up
some of the stranger Force skills out there —
including, of course, Theran Force-listening.
Since the live-action Star Wars universe has
pretty much overwritten Jacen by establishing
Kylo Ren as Han and Leia's only son, it's
highly unlikely that he'll become canon any
time soon. Nevertheless, fans will have noticed
that Ahsoka chose to give one of his most famous
Force abilities to a kid with the same name — and
might see it as a red flag for Syndulla's future.
So what could go wrong? Well, as Kanan
Jarrus' son, Jacen has the potential to be
a truly powerful Force user. The fact that he's
able to use a rare and obscure Jedi skill like
Theran Force-listening with no training suggests a
natural affinity with the Force. And the fact that
he's able to hear what's going on in the World
Between Worlds might hint at a level of power
approaching that of Jacen Solo. Since Jacen is
effectively out of the canon picture and the
younger Jacen's story is largely unwritten, could
the fact that he has access to a similar Force
ability be an ominous hint that he's destined to
follow a similar path? It's hard to say for sure,
but Ahsoka fans will want to keep a close eye
on the young Syndulla as the series draws on.